my name is hamza i was born in 1980
brought up in these estates in london
hackney
growing up i had wonderful loving
parents like with many people i had key
moments that changed my life
one of them is when i embraced islam and
the other is when i doubted it
yes even i had doubts i became muslim
here
on october the 5th 2002 and there were
three main reasons why i embraced islam
one i was intellectually convinced two i
was attracted to islamic values and
three i used to perform salah before i
became muslim
when i became muslim it was such a
blissful experience
however i remember someone responding to
an email of mine regarding the
linguistic miracle of the quran
but i had no clear response that
blissful cloud-like experience was now
becoming a
distant memory as a result my mind
almost left islam but my heart and soul
were on fire
refusing to accept nothing else apart
from the truth of the dean
this tug of war was ripping me apart
but i was not going to fail i remember
praying to allah and in prostration i
was asking him for conviction
how do i explain the linguistic miracle
of the quran without speaking the
language
and that's where it all started i
acquired everything i could on the topic
i spoke to students of knowledge
i bought expensive books i visited
libraries
and to my amazement when i was
researching at the british library here
i found a rare phd entitled towards a
text linguistic definition
of quranic inimitability i asked them
for a copy
but they never got back to me and that's
when i hit a brick wall
so i decided to call talk languages and
request an expert on the quran
when i met my teacher for the first time
i explained my situation
and at that moment he stands up he walks
around his table
he goes to a drawer he picks up some
papers he walks back
and he puts him in front of me and lo
and behold it was the phd i was looking
for
and what's even more amazing he was the
author
dr sami al-halawani from al-azhar
university
i then further developed my ideas on the
topic and i was asked to write a chapter
of the book
the history of the magnificent quran
when i wrote the chapter
the publishers said that it had to be
checked by scholars
being relatively young with not much
experience on the topic it was totally
understandable
however during that period the taoist
scene was quite dark
there was egos nasty competition and i
was thinking of just simply quitting
i was so close to a decision but
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah i received a
text message by the publishers
and they said something along the lines
of the scholars said this is one of the
best things they've read in the english
language
i took this as a sign to continue my
journey in 2009
i joined i era i recalled visiting
chicago for a tour
and there was one brother and i don't
remember his name
ripped into me he said hamza what is all
of this
who are you developing what real impact
are you having
all of this is just a show that really
got to me
it hit me hard when i went back to the
ira office
i broke down crying
it was then i made a commitment that i'm
going to focus
on developing and empowering others that
key milestone
helped me develop advanced training for
iera and it became the basis of my
best-selling book the divine reality
god islam and the mirage of atheism and
the process of writing chapters 13 and
completely obliterated my doubts
i also completed my master's degree in
philosophy and i continued post-graduate
academic research
at the university of london it is
without a doubt
allah planned this journey for me i
realized that my doubts were not purely
intellectual
i needed to connect and to know allah
more
i needed to empower others a year after
my book was published i was asked to
become
aira's ceo alhamdulillah we
increased our operational growth by over
a thousand percent
and we delivered advanced training to
scholars imams
and activists from all around the world
with ira's support
since july 2020 we have moved advanced
our to
sapience institute in nine months we
have already trained over
6 000 muslims published
books written essays produce media and
video content
and much more brothers and sisters
if this story has inspired you then
please
support us in the next phase of our
journey let's follow the prophetic model
of empowering and developing others
start your monthly donation now head
over to
sapienceinstitute.org forward slash
donate or click the link below